yeah we are starting here with some
breaking news at 6 30 on this Wednesday
unfortunately fire uh crews out there
working a mobile home park they did put
the fire out the home though a total
loss yeah very sad you know the mobile
home is near Charleston and the 95
that's where we find Candace Charles
Candace what do we know so far right now
well they're still working on putting
out this fire but what you said is
completely right it is unfortunately a
total loss as you can imagine farker's
up and working tirelessly throughout the
morning and throughout last night trying
to put out fires started by fireworks
unfortunately this was another one that
they tell me was started by a firework
they said they got the call around five
o'clock this morning when they showed up
this mobile home here was completely
engulfed in flames they say that it
likely started in the back of the home
by the trees there the firework maybe
from a different location hit the trees
and then the mobile home came up in
Flames I spoke to the next door neighbor
who told me that this is the second time
that the mobile home caught fire she did
tell me that it was abandoned and also
Clark County Fire Department confirmed
that as well another neighbor here told
me that there was a woman who lived
there recently passed away and it's
since been abandoned
fortunately no one in the neighborhood
no no one at the home next door anyone
is injured but again this home is a
complete loss they did tell me that the
fire is out of course they're here
monitoring and making sure there's no
pop-up flame because unfortunately that
is what happens sometimes with these
situations of course we're continuing to
learn more details about here but again
the main thing is no one is injured and
as we learn more of course we'll bring
you more but for now live from mobile
home park off of Sand Hill Road I'm
Candace Charles 8 News Now